so the youngest kid has the total
Advantage I was the youngest kid I had
the ultimate blueprint by watching my
family I sat back and watched my dad my
mom my brother whoever it may be I sat
back and I paid attention and it was the
ultimate blueprint to how to live life I
have not to live life how not to live
life I realized there was a lot of
people that I got to see were like the
sort of person I didn't want to be like
and that was the reverse role model so I
could look around I could say I really
don't want his relationship with his
wife he doesn't have any Integrity or
tell the truth he can actually achieve a
lot of success in life by avoiding
failure most success in life actually is
avoiding failure you need to not lose
before you can win and the reverse role
model is you weaving your way through a
selection of people that you don't want
to be like and I think that you can get
an awfully long way just by doing that